I'd like to show you something even
stupider Whoopi Goldberg on The View
thank you that's bothering me more I'm
sorry about all of this you know the the
young person that uh the young man they
got for Espionage recently yeah he's do
you know that he's demanding to be
treated exactly the same way as Trump
was he wants to be yes he wants to be
able to go home yeah and do everything
and that's the thing for me that is most
egregious
nobody goes home and no one should be
about nobody nobody is above the law you
should not be walking you should
actually be in the building right that
has the bars on it both of you
well because you're you took you took
documents and gave them to other people
they don't let folks walk around but
suddenly now we have that exception to
the rule and this is the dangerous part
of it there should be no exception I
think the reason there's an exception is
because bail is never supposed to be
punitive right it has to make sure that
that defendant will return they've I'm
sure taking his passport I don't know
what country would take him other than
maybe Putin's Russia or South Africa
yeah he doesn't fly commercial do you
like I mean yeah
but I'm pretty sure that those are the
only two countries that would provide
him
South Korea well from the sounds of the
Saudi Arabia North Korea okay the kid
that she's talking about is that kid
from about what was that about six weeks
ago or so who leaked some classified
documents in a Discord group and now he
is under arrest and we can have an
honest discussion about whether he
should be a rested right now or out on
bail or anything else but what what
Whoopi wants is just because Donald
Trump is accused of something right just
because a D.A whether it's Alvin Bragg
up in New York or it's this Jack Smith
guy just because they basically hand the
indictment that Donald Trump should
automatically be in jail and then all of
the harpies agree and all of the
audience agrees and do you realize how
dangerous that would be if every time
someone is accused of something if we
automatically throw them in jail until
it can be proven do you think that might
be a problem do you think that might be
against due process yes yes you do okay
good
[Music]